é minha tarântula morreu
o pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark sejam
muito bem vindos mas é um peão e hoje
ele vai ter que sentar e hoje eu vou
fazer este vídeo assim mais simples que
expõe mais parado e sentado porque eu
vou falar do assunto sério vou falar do
que vocês tanto perguntam que embarca
onde está a culpa é tua tarde porque ele
não grava mais quanto oferece o que
aconteceu mas afinal de contas nem
tranquila morreu ou não
aqui está a prova um olha aí ela me
trata por quem não sabe eu tenho uma
tarântula de pêssego e isso é uma das
mais perigosas do mundo não ser mais
perigosa mas finalmente é maior do mundo
tem 35 e sim porque não viu esse filho
vai fazer é que não foi um adeus lênin
aranha e da previ ela casar barato e
tudo mais época como barata como rato
como homens é que isso vocês colocaram
voz e violão estiver irritada também
como modelo mas vocês querem ver mais
sobre isso aí o vídeo vai rolar por lá
explica essa coisa sobre ela e pronto
fita branca é mantê-la o carinho dela é
alimentar e fiz tudo certo e indeciso
temperatura desde água eu controlava
tudo porque ela como um animal na
amazônia e quando eu tenho que fornecerá
condição que ela precisa é uma aranha
que transitar entre os 25 e 30 graus
portanto vocês têm de controlar simples
e esse ambiente tem que ser quente e
também tem que ser comigo então é muito
difícil de controlar eu tô deslizou
confirmada está no úmido estava estava
quente estava tudo bem e ela parece
estar feliz é teoria em que aconteceu
uma coisa ela bem chuta com medo deixou
simplesmente deixou coisa que eu não
consigo fazer ainda hoje mas eu também
comecei barata como barata de sempre em
portugal não é claro que o vídeo dá pra
mostrar mas ela comemora barata saísse
um dos amarelos mas continuando ela
ficou a um mês dois meses e comer bem
tudo certinho até que ficou à altura em
que ela deixou de comer por completo ou
nada barata ela não cometeu nada é mais
barato ela não comia um prato barato
assim branca não desvio é que ela
mostrando que sua casa à noite portanto
pensei ok então vou deixar barato e vou
deixar por ser muitas vezes eu saía do
quarto apagão diz bello pensar que era
noite e com medo mas mesmo assim ela não
comia não sei que vamos contactar
socialistas vão contactar aqui e ver o
que se passa com ela ninguém conseguiu
dar uma resposta concreta
depois em mais um selvagem e nunca sei
que o centro e única coisa que podia
fazer era explorar a alimentá la e
continuar a mesma da umidade e
temperaturas um mês passou do espaço 3-4
ainda estavam mais baratas que o
coloquei a minha tia atrás ou seja ela
não comeu pela continuava sem comer mas
muito excitada mesmo para não subir aos
troncos andava por ali ressaltar que
nada não comia ainda mais estranho é
porque eu pensei como é que o animal não
corre consegue ter tanta energia e eu
saí eu não como o fusion fica assim só
porque não tem força mas continuando eu
sei que vocês já devem estar achando que
ela não morreu é porque o do rio voltou
a fazer piada
posso estar muito gente falando pedra
jucá
isso é o que tem frustrado porque quando
você tem um animal de estimação vocês
têm a responsabilidade de cuidar deu
porque eu não está ali só para enfeitar
aparelho só preparando e vocês têm que
dar comida controlar um ambiente tudo
que ela consultou bós filho e
principalmente aquilo era um sonho desde
pequeno que eu tinha de ter uma
tranqüilidade se ela morrer isso eu me
senti muito mal entretanto nesses meses
foram passando e eu vim aqui pra dar
colômbia e trouxemil perante uma óbvia a
mulher se ela ainda sente um pouquinho
porque ela estava um pouco agitado não
possuía o que estava a acontecer porque
dentro do carro abandonado há muito não
possuíam ganham agora o grupo está com
medo capital ela só se chipre beber água
eu pensei ok ela saberá ver está tudo
bem está hidratada é o mais importante e
depois mais uma vez uma semana depois
ela deixou de beber água deixou de fazer
nada fico quieto só que foi precisamente
por isso que não temos treinava porque
eu pensei que ela estava a morrer eu não
me sentia em fazer um vídeo com ela
assim estado hebreu estar doente foi
pensar o que eu vou falar um trabalho
ver o que se passa o limpa do ponto de
vista ela está muito favorável é alguém
saiba é mas encontraram um cenário
exótico é muito difícil e muita gente
viu isso
agora ela pode sair na frente vamos pra
lá então mais um tempinho vamos ver
antes de novo treinador vamos ver o que
acontece o que aconteceu o rabo dela de
que o caminho aí eu já digo não dela é
verdade muito você se pergunta o nome de
mini transat digo 'não há paz consigo
uma burrada dela com sua se já o cônsul
ficar uma batata em grande e tudo pelo
que ela tenha por cima com sua
desaparecer
bia fica assim sem pelo comércio sabe
quando você está em cima do gol
e começa a inchar o que quer ficar com
infecção isso é o rabo dela bateu por
dentro porque tinha tipo 1 é uma
invenção gigante eo if que estava fiquei
porque escutava ficar assim meio
amarelada e e branco e farofa a bela não
perdeu o pique ou não mas continua a
esfera quanto mais fé depois disto
acontecer falar com as pessoas certas e
terá opinião muita gente havia apenas
duas conclusões duas só uma delas era
ela estar doente infectada e irmão que
muito em breve porque porque já não
havia fundamento por rafael já estava
inchado - ela assuma de cinema já não
havia muito a fazer e aí é
responsabilidade minha ea morte de que o
animal de companhia ou vai passar ainda
não sabe se ela morreu segunda opção ela
estava passando por uma metamorfose
internet não tem um esqueleto que é tipo
um excluído exterior saem de eletrônicos
em maio de 2007 é isso mesmo é
basicamente ter a dupla não tenha
escolhido por dentro como nós e nós
temos hoje pois temos carro elas é
contrário à parte fora é que é o
esqueleto de chamar sedvan letão porque
é que o é
vocês perceberam netbooks coletada para
fora e por dentro é regra e por entender
que elas fibras que faz com que ela se
movimenta e quando ela começou ontem
para cristiana e fica muito grande elas
basicamente já não cabem dentro daqueles
que lehto então tem que haver uma
mudança e mudança é feita após essa
informação acho que isso é explicável
pessoal de alguém perceber tanto mas
acho que é isso então pessoas por aí
se ela morresse morria isso ela fosse
por causa do descuido me expor ainda
mais é um processo que demora algum
tempo então eu só fiquei à espera e
neste último que sair de casa de manhã
eu saí de casa também é evitar
ambulantes em casa e fiquei super
assustado porque ela participar mesmo
morta há inclusive melhor o contexto é
muito importante e muito importante
quanto esse caso até então estava de
pernas pro ar
esse é um sinal nós né barato com mota
para falar e pronto está morto ela não
morreu mas mesmo assim não sair de casa
tão complemento tenta esquecer o assunto
para não estragar o dia é porque estava
triste manhã quando eu não tenho casa
mas logo depois voltei às nove da noite
eu acho que eu voltei
olhei para o caso do vídeo que tinha
consigo meu deus aconteceu o melhor mas
como a solução é minha terão uma segunda
cascata seria o gosto e com muito grande
e vocês estão vendo aqui ó está aqui
isso aqui é excluir incrível está
intacta e você já conseguem vir aqui as
garras dela
olha só fazia parte dela fez felizmente
deu certo ela estava e mais fácil de
saúde e eu gostava muito de ter fumado
processo porque é um processo muito
lindo depara em aceitar sim do osso e
não consegui filmar isso porque eu nunca
estaria à espera que não aconteça como é
que o momento mas eu vou passar agora um
vídeo só vocês podem ver precisamente o
que aconteceu
[Música]
mas claro assim que o vi que ela estava
fora da caixa que filmei um novo olha
sua imagem olha aí ela vai completar nem
pernas pro ar e tem ali que era parceiro
lado meu muito lindo mas mesmo assim eu
fiquei preocupado porque porque ela
estava de pernas por hora e para eu não
sabia se era possível a tam atua ter
morrido com o processo porque deve
causar dor ou estava viva mas eu também
não tinha tocado por interferir com essa
metamorfose sei lá então eu não tinha e
fica à espera continuar e ficar à espera
que isto aconteceu há mais de três
semanas em troca a única coisa que eu
fiz foi o cara se não é só escolher só
poder ser anos era móvel ser duro que
era mais uns 20 delas em brinquedos bem
9 mil ela ficou muito linda 0 m terão
uma pessoa do que estranho é preto
porque se perdemos pelos novos tento no
fim ela ficou muito maior já que nós
como aquela tática toda esticada jogos
mostra usá lo assim
e finalmente ela mexer se ela estava bem
estava sem cheiro olha olha aí mas
felizmente eu sei lá como ela não morreu
porque o castigo a minha filha que
morreu é porque é mesmo clapton eu
coloquei esse tempo pra vocês sentirem o
que eu senti quando vi a minha parada é
porque eu fiquei assustado quando vi e
vocês com certeza ficarão os estoques
combinam este portanto quase sentiram
foi consentido é mesmo mesmo agora que
vocês também querem saber é qual é o
nome de minha taranto e no outro dia nós
estávamos lá na sala todos eo bebidas de
bola pra ele e por que ela chama de
traidor de brigadeiro e faz tudo para
ser um brigadeiro
então eu conheço o pessoal ela chama se
brinca até comentei em baixo que fica
melhor é brigadeiro ou é brincadeira
para lá pra saber como está a nossa
tarefa agora ela é que está pessoal
nosso trabalho como podem gostar muito
simples porque o que já observava ao
máximo e vamos lá ver onde ela está
com certeza estou aqui mas tem que ter
um contágio em casa e não sei se ela
está em casa
meu deus eu tenho medo porque ela agora
anda muito agressiva saiu agora
o tae hwi vai eu sou também olha aí tá
muito maior é só esperando lá na
brigadeiro agora não dá pra perceber
muito também dela porque ela está
incluída mas quando ela abre assim fica
muito grande
o ou foi só a sistema de defesa ativo e
eu não posso ficar aqui não fixei
mostrar isso aí outra coisa pessoal eu
vou passar aqui uma meta e vou lançar um
desafio
nós conseguimos chegar o sangue lights
neste vídeo eu vou comer
o esqueleto da linha branca eu vou
fritar no óleo e vou comer assim com tal
a equipe tem carinho eu já não chega
muito tempo mas vamos tentar não esqueça
de dizer o que tem que fazer agora
porque eu não sei só por ser uma tarefa
por favor ajude época não culpe por
falar em comida eu tenho uma coisa pra
dizer que fiquei fiquei porque é bom só
para vocês terem uma idéia eu tenho
andado muito viciada que nos jogos que
dão acesso à comida você já ouviu mais
uns jogos da comida pra vocês comerem
por comida para comer é básico inclusive
outros garante que enquanto fazendo
medida mas vou explicar para fora foi
uma aplicação que é a e bonucci essa aí
onde é um conjunto de vários jogos como
vocês podem jogar
e além de vocês vamos ganhando e
passando os níveis vocês vão ganhar
ofertas ofertas que vai dar acesso à
comida muito fácil vocês podem ir ao
banheiro kinga pisa é ter a pele ou
cabeceou movimento que só me deixa feliz
porque eu jogarei do primeiro mês de
2012 e vocês podem baixar próximo iphone
etapa podem machucar a vontade à vontade
o jogo é completamente gratuito e vocês
podem ver forma ilimitada tipo sem
possuir cnh não era eu até fiz um vídeo
promo instagram eu acho que na altura
tinha tipo de sete ofertas e agora tem
30 e não 40 42 cunha ou tossia muito 16
42 profetas eu posso 42 vezes com
ofertas começam hambúrguer de frango
para chegar lá é igual não fechem os
jogos também jovem de minions como os
atos da opel em um nível ruim complicado
chegou nem eu pude na estreia mas isso é
fácil de uma boa e outra ruim mas mandar
ela ir nem todo a não enganem
aí nosso pai falhou
é ó oi que jogando jogando comida do
almoço eu vou ter mas é este pequeno
estado vídeo de chen muito mais aqui no
espírito que seja muito familiares do
comutran quanto ao lado de três fiquem
vai até a próxima
[Música]